israel says that one objective in its
gaza airstrikes has been to destroy an
underground
tunnel network used by hamas the tunnels
are used to smuggle goods including
weapons which are prevented
by an israeli blockade from reaching
gaza over land and sea it's not the
first time that israel has sought to
[ __ ] the underground
infrastructure
israeli airstrikes hitting gaza only one
of a series of strikes that the idf has
carried out on
alleged military targets
we've hit an hamas naval unit and we
continue to strike at underground
infrastructure the hamas metro
the so-called metro is a network of
tunnels dozens of kilometers long
believed to be
under the surface of gaza some beneath
its cities
as well as smuggling tunnels connecting
the strip to neighboring egypt
an animated video released by the israel
defense forces provides what it calls an
inside look
at an hamas metro tunnel
for over a decade gaza's tunnels have
been lifelines to the outside world
passageways for importing essential
goods as well as weapons
under a long-standing israeli blockade
they've also repeatedly been the targets
of israeli attacks
in january this year a senior hamas
commander cautioned against continued
use of the tunnels
the enemy has discovered a large part of
the tunnels
of the resistance
during the years they've prepared for a
campaign
militants arrested salia after the video
was released
but the claims of the idf that it's only
targeting the tunnel system or other
militant sites in the gaza strip
are disputed on saturday an israeli
airstrike
destroyed a high rise that housed al
jazeera the associated press
and other media organizations
press freedom groups accused the
military which claimed the building
housed hamas military intelligence
of trying to sense the coverage of
israel's offensive in the densely packed
enclave
israel says hamas is using palestinian
civilians as human shields while critics
say israel
is using disproportionate force
earlier this year the international
criminal court launched an investigation
into possible war crimes committed by
israel and palestinian militants
during the last war in 2014 calls are
being made for a similar investigation
into the current conflict